hey folks Daniel do I hear from gamespot
showing off via the twitch app which is
coming up March 11th the day of
titanfall is release or rather the
updated version of it which will allow
you to stream games if you're currently
using twitch on your Xbox one this is
what it looks like you can watch loads
of people playing video games but you
cannot broadcast yourself like you can
on your PlayStation 4 however in a
couple of days time you'll be able to
access twitch to look like this and
essentially this is letting you do what
the PlayStation 4 does I'm actually kind
of a little bit more in terms of options
and settings so you can search for
streams you can go via game like you
count on the PC and streams that you
follow are here so currently Patrick our
good friends at Giant Bomb is doing the
binding of Patrick so he's streaming
that right now and so yeah all this
stuff is stuff you can kind of do stay
at the moment watch other people you
know follow them from here I could
report Patrick if he's being a real real
jerk but let's get into the what the
update is going to have which is the
broadcast function so when you click on
this first of all actually setting this
up was super easy and you don't even
have to input your twitch password you
basically am asked to associate it with
your gamertag
on your Xbox one console and it gives
you a code so you'll want to have a PC
or a laptop or something close by you
log into twitch on your computer and
then input that code and it
automatically associate sit with your
gamertag and actually automatically logs
you in as well so if you hit broadcast
it'll snap on over here and essentially
you know simple settings but there's
actually a lot more stuff you can do in
here that you can in the PlayStation 4
version so I'm going to call this test
for now
and if we head into the settings I'll
show you some of the extra features you
can do your picture picture here you can
snap it into various different corners
if you want you can turn off connect as
well if you don't have to do that if you
don't to show yourself hey I'm playing a
video game hey I which is kind of cool a
feature because obviously with some
games there's a hood elements or you
know information that your picture
picture might be blocking turning off
the microphone all that stuff but here's
an interesting one you can actually set
the quality yourself so the recommended
changes based on your internet it's
basically constantly and at least at
this stage when you're setting up and
establishing water kind of a good upload
rate will be yeah but you can lock it if
you so wish and then it gives you your
and broadcast hot and one off so it's
pretty easy to set up we have to start
broadcast here we are broadcasting and I
have no viewers hello no viewers yeah
and then all you have to do is double
tap the home button swap over and you're
in the game so it's it's kind of cool
because you can basically view yourself
you can see what's going on you can read
the chat as you're playing and it does
take up quite a lot of real estate on
the right and because it's not like
overlaid over the gameplay it kind of
letterboxes the gameplay as well which
is you know depending on the size of
your television that may or may not be
irritating but that's kind of just one
of those realities of a broadcasting on
the internet yeah it's a snap back all
you have to do is double tap the home
button and you can stop the broadcast
you can even go in here and tweak some
of the settings so you can swap around
your pip while you're doing your
broadcast turn off your microphone if
you're gonna start cursing and the one
thing you cannot do is change the
quality midstream and so I think it's
probably best to stick on the
recommended one and at that stage but it
seems to be working pretty good here
yeah so as you can see here I am I'm
playing the battlefield we got a bunch
of people in the chat talking mess seven
viewers it's pretty good there's a
little bit of lag on the video here but
then
because twitch has that like 50 60
second like thing at the moment I guess
it's not gonna make much of the
difference but I move in my hand like
faster in real life it's like I'm
watching a version of myself dancing in
the past murdering people from the sky
montana corner died quad bike great
awesome
I think that's a good way to sign off
murdering people from the sky now yeah
so that starts to twitch streaming right
here on the Xbox one the app is coming
out March 11th you'll be able to do all
this yourself works pretty good it's a
you know not the most complex app in the
world but it does all the PlayStation 4
wonders I'm a little bit more so
hopefully some of that stuff will come
to that and Sony's console to be able to
murder people killed are gone
alright I better get back to work you
sixteen people watching my stream thank
you very much and all you people
watching this video on the Internet yeah
thanks for hanging out here and look
forward to streaming yourself on March
11th bye